GABRIEL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT FEDERAL AGENTS
WORKING TO SECURE OUR BORDERS
AREN'T THE ONLY ONES IN DANGER
FROM THE INCREASING X
IS ONE OF THEM.
>> GATES, YOU PATHETIC PIECE OF
BLANK YOU KNOW THAT I COULD BLOW
YOUR BLANK HEAD AND CLEAN OFF
YOUR SHOULDERS FROM MORE THAN A
MILE AWAY?
WATCH YOUR BACK, YOU PATHETIC
PIECE OF BLANK.
I'M COMING AFTER YOU.
>> Tucker: THAT'S ABOUT AS
CLEAR CUT AS IT COULD BE.
THOSE ARE THREATS.
HERE'S THE REMARKABLE PART.
ACCORDING TO GATES, THE FBI HAS
ALREADY IDENTIFIED THE PERSON
THERE'D A FEDERAL FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR HAS DECIDED TO NOT
PRESS CHARGES.
>> I RESERVED WORD LATE LAST
WEEK THAT THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WHERE THIS INDIVIDUAL
LIVED HAD REVIEWED THE MESSAGE
AND HAD DEEMED THEM UNKNOWN
THREAT.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A CRIME.
A FEDERAL CRIME TO MAKE THESE
TYPES OF THREATS AGAINST ANY
FEDERAL OFFICIAL.
THIS CONGRESS, I SHOULD SAY, WE
ARE ON RECORD FOR 10,000 THREATS
AGAINST MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, AND
I COME DOWN MIGHT CONDEMN THEM
WHETHER THEY ARE AGAINST.
THIS IS NO WAY TO OPERATE WITHIN
OUR COUNTRY.
I JUST WONDER, IS IT THE FACT
THAT I'VE BEEN A CRITIC OF SOME
OF THE SENIOR OFFICIALS OF THE
FBI?
THAT LEADS TO DIFFERENT PEOPLE
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO THREATEN ME
AS OPPOSED TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY GET ARRESTED WHO HAVE
THREATENED ILHAN OMAR.
THOSE PEOPLE ACTUALLY GET
ARRESTED WHEREAS WHEN PEOPLE
THREATEN CONSERVATIVES.
I HOPE THERE IS NOT A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
>> Tucker: WHO IS THIS
PROSECUTOR WHO TOLD YOU WHAT WE
JUST LISTEN TO, CLEARLY A THREAT
OF VIOLENCE, WAS SOMEHOW NOT A
THREAT?
>> IT WAS A U.S. ATTORNEY FOR
THE NORTHERN DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY WOULD BRING NO CHARGES.
THAT WE ARE JUST SUPPOSED TO
DEAL WITH THAT.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THREATS TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS SERVED WHEN OUR
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE FIDELITY TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS.
PRIME YOU AT A PUBLIC EVENT
EVERY MEMBER OF CONGRESS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PROTECT THE DISTRICT
REGARDLESS OF THEIR VIEWPOINT.
>> HAVE YOU RECEIVED ANY SUPPORT
FROM YOUR DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES
QUESTION MUST TAKE A LOOK BEEN A
CRAZY FEW WEEKS FOR ME.
A MEMBER OF ANTIFA ASSAULT ME AT
A TOWNHOME MEETING.
STEPHANIE MURPHY OF FLORIDA
CONDEMNED IT.
SHE WAS THE ONLY ONE WHO
PETE BUTTIGIEG STAFF MEMBER SO
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD THROW ON ME.
I RECEIVED THESE THREATENING
MESSAGES.
NO PROSECUTOR SEEMED TO BE
INTERESTED IN THOSE CASES.
THIS IS NO WAY TO GET TOGETHER
AND SOLVE THE PROBLEMS FOR THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S NO WAY TO GOVERN, AND I
WISH THERE WOULD BE MORE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR